maybe Australia on the seas
okay
what's happening [ __ ]
you thought you were gonna go to bed
earlier uncle joy having that [ __ ] you
know smoke some [ __ ] refri picked up
that picked up the [ __ ] the white
from perennials and the [ __ ] gorilla
from perennial you understand me with
him when that was the white the white
though and my personal [ __ ] bucket so
I had a scoop of backed up with toe jam
and fingernail polish no Jeep we're
gonna get [ __ ] stoned to the gills my
[ __ ] trusted [ __ ] friends least I
had is he ain't drop by he's already got
a thousand milligrams I got 500 in me
but God forbid God knows what's lurking
in my system from the days before you
it's late night what the [ __ ] with you
do sit there go to bed yet you're
watching some stupid TV show if you're
not watching that show on [ __ ] HBO
and the night you slip in anyway and get
a little breeze from Venice hold on one
sec
tremendous
[ __ ] utterly tremendous I could taste
the [ __ ] thing of it
his toenail right that some aluminum
foil from [ __ ] because no from
nicotine gum you're on fire
a lot of money
for my umbrella I'm proposing me
this is every night when he comes over
that smoke this is tremendous
what's going on beautiful people uncle
Joey here it's [ __ ] up but you gotta
get [ __ ] up on the Lord tonight you
understand me the Lord today something
different Jesus wakes up everybody's
happy you got to do your thing you
better keep breathing over there I got
some [ __ ] gorilla for you not gorilla
go just the gorilla
and look how nice that is
hey you gotta do what you gotta do [ __ ]
no there's nothing to clear it's gone it
took everything I know [ __ ] the hairs
left in my lungs there's nothing absorb
and this goes straight to [ __ ]
there's times like fart unless you smoke
it Sam it just happens
nice
but my [ __ ] poker disappeared like
gently there's my poker right there it's
all open
I'm back [ __ ] and full and full
effect
a little late night meeting here you
know what the [ __ ] what else he undo it
your time getting on read a book about
what somebody boozy gonna read before
you die lucky you still the same [ __ ]
dead end I'm reading what do you [ __ ]
read
[Music]
it's a beautiful night American people
that Australia is in England I know you
tap then you know I love you
[ __ ] it's a pleasure to be
smoking reefer with people
internationally right now you understand
me
we're a force to be reckoned with [ __ ]
sons of anarchy what a real bill that's
a TV show [ __ ] anybody could put on a
t-shirt put sunglasses on us you just
keep going so nice you just think it's
funny when caught
the floppy hair
how did that happen like the jewel from
your fingers would make a turn off the
pipe
Sunday night you'll be worried about
[ __ ] ridiculous gives a [ __ ] about
particular gems a
this is why nothing want some smug
complexion gotta be in shape you gotta
do bonnets every [ __ ] day so this
don't happen you could you can hold your
breath underwater for two minutes I
can't hold my breath and [ __ ] 20
seconds but the same difference
you got worse than AIDS you got that
[ __ ] lizard blood in that taco place
Eva
[Music]
that's it that that baby just checking
in with you [ __ ] let you know
yokel Joey's here was mad [ __ ]
buddy
we saw yet smoke and sacrifice and you
understand me for the order ain't no
[ __ ] fake people around here we just
smoker from the heart you understand me
this reefer smoke goes straight to your
[ __ ] heart you could see it I can see
little real people on when they come up
to minute the smoke is pounded what's
something ready for another hit [ __ ]
yeah this club in your shirt we'll get
some [ __ ] minds match my [ __ ] anyway we
got to take two steps to the rear and
get out of here
I'm happy you checked in wherever the
[ __ ] you are around the globe you
understand me that's how we do it
promote love around the [ __ ] globe
smoke Aretha just talking to each other
here like regular people I don't have
glasses I don't have a cup of coffee
lady you think I'm [ __ ] Pierre cardan
nothing we show up with a [ __ ] up pipe
and a big line of [ __ ] it you understand
me if you're not gonna show up like that
go [ __ ] your mother go you ranch
dressing or whatever stay black and have
a great week start off the week with a
[ __ ] bang who smokes weed the duck
that's not even I'm [ __ ]
trick-or-treating I understand me look
at least say I live oh I love you
[ __ ] Oh